[Music]
can i take this point further forwards
then because you seem to be drilling
down to the idea of anthropomorphic and
proper more formalization as an essence
of computers could you program a
computer to anthropomorphise
and come closer to what it means to be
human using that kind of model
give it an embodied body to be embodied
in in the data
um
i think you can get closer and i worry
about the extent to which we have done
this because we do fool people
this comes back a little to the point
that was just made
i think part of another part of the
reason going further from ken was just
saying that we over identify with
computers now is because they use
language and for a long time we
justified uh killing people by
dehumanizing them and calling them
barbarians barbarian is literally people
who don't speak the same language as me
um and we ate animals that didn't talk
more often than the animals that did
talk um so i i think that we're we are
again this at this implicit level we're
so social we're so set up to become
sort of a crowd computing machine
that that when little things trigger us
like even having a robot shaped like a
person or a statue shaped like a person
makes us behave like there's a person in
the room
and so i i think
that kind of thing may be very hazardous
to us and maybe a vector by which
corporations and governments alter
social behavior
in ways that we may not like or maybe
that we do like we may choose to be
nudged that way by having herds of other
people around us but i doubt it or
perhaps we are already being nudged that
way we yeah no that is
actually so
so how can this collective wisdom i have
in the panel here you know mitigate
against that to anyways it will
encourage human beings to have a much
more mature and understanding
relationship with this terrifying future
that you're suggesting
what can we do about it i i my first
paper we suggested that uh
it was called just an artifact and we
were trying to get people over these
weird they only over identify with ai
when it's shaped like a person
incidentally i was in a lab they had
loads of different kinds of robots
and but there was one robot that was
exactly shaped like a person that was
supposed to become a person actually i i
tried to do it too
so we tried to make this robot person
but anyway people said oh it's unethical
to unplug that just because it was
shaped like a person they didn't care
about the other ones which actually
worked and that robot didn't work at the
time
i'd say you know
with the question of ethics i mean
surely what's what's important with that
is um the agency and the subjectivity of
any ai right and this comes back again
to this question i mean at least if
you're thinking about the rights of
robots as people are beginning to speak
about and so on um this is the question
that comes back to duplication
simulation if a computer is a mere
human simulant
um a replicant as it were um then we
there's really very little reason to
accord them any moral agency as i
wouldn't to my computer or mobile phone
except as property perhaps but not in
itself only instrumentally
so again this question of ethics really
comes down to again metaphysics or
sentience how do we understand the
relation between matter and mind this is
crucial and it cannot be
explained away
in law what we want is a body to kick
and a soul to damn
and the the body to kick of course
exists because the it's made out of
joanna's you know plastic and metal uh
but it doesn't have peter's soul to damn
i should point out you don't need a i
mean i'm not advocating in any way
dualism you know what i'm saying is
because we don't understand matter
properly we don't there might be an
intrinsic aspect of sentience within
mata
but that um but the computational aspect
of the activity of matter
we've got no reason to believe that is
it that is the taking that one step
further forward could you imagine a
computer program that might generate a
psychotic experience or a psychedelic
experience for a computer
uh for well it can it can create one for
a human certainly well no i'm not quite
the human computer but for the computer
itself well i mean again that's
completely dependent on the question as
to whether um a a computer or an
algorithm or ai in any sense can have
sentience this is the very important
question we you cannot talk about
perception and processing outputs
behavior in this sense there's a much
deeper question does all of this
activity
um
make emerge
consciousness or is it
correlated or related in any way to
sentence this is the key question okay
so so coming back to done it i would say
the one paper you really want to read is
one that says why computers can't feel
pain
all right so coming back to the body to
kick who cares if there's a body to kick
if you can go out and buy another one
right that's exactly the same it's mass
manufactured and you've backed
everything up
right so the issue is about uh pain i i
don't we can we can we're already
arguing about consciousness i want to
argue about sentience i want to come
back to this thing about how can we help
people get over their their their
misconceptions
the um
we in our first paper we suggested that
as people had more of experience with ai
they would get over this so like with
movies you know people used to scream
and faint because king kong was on the
screen and now like little kids watch it
they're not afraid of it um can we get
maybe with more experience we get over
that
but so far we haven't been seeing that
and i think that's because we've gotten
so good at
our corporations have gotten very good
at triggering
uh
what and not with all ai the vast
majority of ai we don't feel human is
human like like google great ai nobody
thinks it's a human
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you